[Music]  Jamie Foxx and Katie Holmes looking like  a 20-18 version of love and basketball  et has these exclusive pics of the pair  hitting the gym together in LA on  Valentine's Day Holmes was decked out in  her sporty workout clothes while Foxx  wore a sweater and jeans with his  fitness gear seemingly packed away in a  Nike bag photog spotted the two adorably  goofing off together as they headed  inside but we are living for this moment  Katie Holmes busting out a little dance  number during the casual stroll the  low-key pair has been seen in public  more frequently these days we're  inclined to call them inseparable at  this point after the workout session  Foxx was seen walking out to the car  with Holmes trailing not too far behind  him  [Music]